this is a production of cornell
university
hi everyone my name is chine dussy and
i'm presenting on genetic
improvement and chemical
characterization of garrett quality
of cassavagar equality um
so here is my outline so as
liam said cassava fees hundred millions
of people
yeah so most of these people are in the
tropics and subtropical
um areas of the world and um
they it's originated from south america
and it's
it's been grown like over so many places
because of its numerous uses so cassava
is used for food
by man anima also consume the leaves and
it's used for industrial raw material
especially in the production of scotch
and bio eternal
it's a resilient plant it can grow on
marginal so it's usually so is
where you can't grow other crops cassava
can try
very well in such areas so it's firstly
becoming a crop for
food security
and it's also grown mainly for its roots
um because of the high moisture content
and cyanide
content of cassava it is usually um
converted to other forms and so it can
have longer shelf life and then the
cyanide content can be reduced so most
times it's consumed as
in chips and boyd or it's used in making
fufu or gary sofufu is a rated
and buoyed and pounded cassava and
um my work focus is on gary and
it's derived product called eba so to
make gary you have to peel the cassava
and then wash after washing you grind
the cassava
the water or the water and ferment so
this has two variants
some people the water and bag the
cassava allowed to ferment before
dewatering
so in the region where this experiment
is taking place uh we usually
do water and ferment at the same time so
the watering is done with a
hydraulic press so it can take like two
to three days
depending on the method and choice so
after the watering you you fitter or
sieve
to into fine particles before roasting
with
a cast iron pot and then you have your
final product
which is called gary
so then i mentioned ebba so ebba is a
reconstituted gallery so most people eat
about as meal because and gary can be
eating in different forms like
um you can snack hungary and you can
actually eat it as a full meal
so um to make a bar you have to use a
hot
water or a boiling water depends on the
kind of garage so some people
people before you buy a guy you have to
ask the seller if it's
hot water kind of gary or boiling water
kind of carry so
you don't have to you have to do that if
not you get something
you never wanted to get and um
why am i interested in gary so about 70
of cassava
is consumed as gary gary has a longer
shelf life and it's easy to transport
compared to other products and it can be
eaten in different forms as i've said
earlier
so cassava breeders over the world have
developed
um disease resistance high yielding
resistance and varieties that are rich
in micronutrients
content but there's a decline in the
adoption of these varieties
so and one of the hypotheses is that
breeders did not incorporate
the attributes especially the century
and the processing attribute that the
consumers
want so most times because consumers and
the farmers end up
rejecting this or not adopting these
varieties
so the objective of my research is to
determine the sensory attribute of
the two muslim of gary and its
reconstituted product
that is the eba to develop high
phenotyping evaluation alternative for
important chemical constituents and the
sensory attributes
and to estimate the genotype by
environment interaction and heritability
of care equality
i just want to determine the
relationship between on farm and on
station measure in a tri-coat experiment
so the research is divided into three
components the breeding quality study
the sensory evaluation
and the tripod and current experiment
so for the breeding quality study
um the is going on right now in two
locations
um the population is the um decay c2
population and there are 204 genotypes
um i have two locations uh um toby
there are two reps and is an aflaptis
design so right now data has been
collated on the
agronomic disease and the yield
data and you'd and then um
some genotypes were selected for gary
and they were processed into gary
um so for the physical chemical property
i've already
i've just i'm only able to do the dry
matter content
by grab a gravimetric anti-metric method
so right now i'm
yet to do the the
the other in physiochemical properties
and then the functional
properties they on the screen are the
list of the
of the properties i i'm interested in
then for the sensory evaluation
um i'll be using the flash profiling
approach so flash profiling as
the name implies is rapid and sensory
evaluation
so it requires a minimal training of the
panelists compared to
other essential evaluation where you
have to do rigorous training of the
panelists but the thing is you need to
get panelists that are regular consumers
of the product so they can know what to
look out for
and this um panelists have to be able to
um explain their their senses they get
from testing each product
and for flash profiling you combine you
the the the panelists have to come up
with words so you don't have to give
them the word before the
the evaluation they come up with words
to describe the
samples and then they comparatively
evaluate and rank
the samples so it's quite fast you can
evaluate about 10
about up to 40 samples
so for me i'm i'll be um for this
experiment i'll evaluate 40 samples
using 20 panelies each panelist will be
given
five samples per session and some
sections would be like
two sections per day so to evaluate like
10 samples per day
so this is just like the schematics on
how to
evaluate in flash profiling so this they
generate lexicon so since different
um panelists will come up with different
things to describe the samples
after that i have to i'll bring you guys
together i will compile each and the
lazy cons
and then sort out redundance and then
finally they will evaluate the samples
compare the samples and do the ranking
so this is like the this is a sample of
the ballots
to use for the flash profiling so they
will come up with a list of the
attributes and then they just read this
is
sample a sample b to the end and then
they rank
the samples from low to high
so the next experiment is a tricot
anchoring
experiment so tripod is a trading
comparison of technology so tree samples
are giving
them to farmers to grow on their feet so
right now in nigeria we have about
300 farmers evaluating 30 um
genotypes across um four locations
so this makes so at the end they will
rank varieties across them
based on from worst to best or
and then they will know which variety
is best in each location and um
so my experiment is just to anchor that
tri-cut experiment by
just looking at the um what the farmer
is doing compared to
what is going on on trial so
i'm going to get like 21 farmers to
evaluate three
the same cassava on the tripod
experiment
and they will take data on different
time points
and um rank the ergonomic yield and then
gary quality
from best to worst and then they do the
rating on the scale of one to five
like at the end of the whole section to
rate each
cas each product on this each variety on
a scale of one to five
so right now i just have um
some of the ergonomic that i'm still
working on my data so i have the
i just did a correlation study for each
of the location
this is for the gary treats so i did
them
gary and like the proportion of gary pay
a fresh weight
it's called gary here so it's positively
correlated with the dmc that is not
the relationship is not strong and um
gary peplotz is um very compared to the
net plot and for some reason is
negatively correlated with the
oven dry method of oven dry method of
fame
specific of dry matter content and then
is positively correlated with the dmc of
um using in the specific gravity method
and the same thing up
is what is obtained in decay
so i look at the distribution of most of
the guy retreat and they are like
they vary across location the trades
very across location
and so i just picked up two just two
trades to show
how they vary across the locations
and then i look at the heritability of
some of the agronomic traits
and for in different
locations and any combined um analysis
so i got them in for the number of
fruits
there is a hair stability of 0.48 and
then a dry matter by oven dry method
in both location
was lower it was low compared to dry
matter by specific gravity metal
and the even um the combined analysis
analysis gave the same
low dry matter compared to the specific
gravity metal
so in summary they trade vary across
location the heritability for the traits
and the inheritability also varies with
trait and location
and then there's positive correlation
although is weak
between dmc oven dry metal and dmc by
specific gravity metal
so work is still going on i have to i
have the nearest data
so i'm going to analyze them
and then the tripods will be due
by the end of this month and then the
central evaluation we are yet to do that
so i have to do it when i
get back to nigeria
so i want to acknowledge the nrcri
team for their efforts
is this what won't have gone anywhere
without them this year i'm so grateful
and i also want to thank my supervisory
committee and
um next gen cassava and every other
person
thank you
so i welcome questions
thanks for the wonderful talk
shenanigans
um so you can either write down your
questions in the chat
or you can also raise your hand and i
will
ask you to unmute or just unmute if you
want to do that
hey chin and dozy i had a question about
the uh
the fermentation step
so do
what what what microbes contribute to
that fermentation and
is there a uh is there a genetic
variance to that um
like do different varieties have
different inoculums
or is that an inoculant source that's
added to
the production line how does how does
that work
so normally the fermentation takes this
naturally you don't add
anything so but for my research is not
the
i don't i'm not like this is far beyond
the scope of this
work we're not looking at the back the
inoculum and the bacteria or
the fermentation process but before you
get gary it has to pass through
fermentation process
yeah but it's natural fermentation you
don't have to
add bacteria or stuff
okay i'm just curious yeah it's not true
all right thank you
hi trinidas i have a quick question uh
thanks for your interesting seminar
um you mentioned there's hot water
versus boiling
water is that a genetic varietal
difference is there nutrient composition
or is it
something with the processing so we are
yet to know that we don't know what
causes it
so i think that's part of this research
i hope
at the end of the research you will know
what's why
you need to have different temperature
water to make different kind of eba or
different kind of curry
interesting thanks will sorry this is
john luke
um interesting question did you mean do
people do
do the one kind uh do do hot water as
opposed to boiling water
with some varieties and and boiling
water with other varieties
or well i'm not sure i understood your
question
right so i think what i'd heard was that
when you went to the market you were
told
what you were buying was either to be
boiling or hot water maybe i
misinterpreted
what caused you know the person at the
market selling it to determine something
was
one or the other
yeah so most times these people that
sell must have used it
because some some sellers buy why others
um
process themselves and sell so they did
they already know because they've
already tried it in their houses and
they
know that this is not good for hot water
or this is good
for boiling water so so they have to
tell you if you don't tell the if
you don't ask them they just give you
and then when you go home and try to
realize yourself that
it is for hot water and it's an
otherwise
yeah so right now we don't know what
causes that
characteristics in gary
so we are still working on that
great thank you so much that was a
wonderful talk
and the last talk of our seminar series
for
the fall semester
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu